>> HE DIDN'T RAISE ANY
CONCERN?
>> AND CONCERNS WERE NOT
RAISED.
>> Sean: WE HAVE MORE ON
LORETTA LYNCH'S COMMENTS IN
THE SHOW.
FIRST TO JOINING TO US REACT
TO THE STORY TONIGHT AUTHOR
OF BEST SELLER TRUMPED UP.
THE PLITEDDIZATION OF
POLITICAL DIFFERENCES
ENDANGERS DEMOCRACY.
FAMED HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR
ALAN DERSHOWITZ RAIDED THE
PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL
ATTORNEY'S HOME AND OFFICE
AND HOTEL ROOM.
RUSSIA COLLUSION HAS NOW
BECOME STORMY DANIELS
PAYMENT BY HIS OWN LAWYER.
>> I THINK ACTUALLY THIS
DOES SHOW US SOMETHING
SIGNIFICANT ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATION.
I DO THINK A DECISION HAS
BEEN MADE FROM THE VERY TOP
THAT THE MURAL INVESTIGATION
IS STICK TO RUSSIA COLLUSION
THE CAMPAIGN, OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE ANYTHING ELSE
RELATING TO TRUMP'S BUSINESS
DEALINGS, ANY ALLEGED
RELATIONSHIPS PAYMENTS TO
WOMEN WILL BE GIVEN OVER TO
THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW
YORK.
NOW, THEY WILL WORK
TOGETHER.
AND THIS MAY BE AN ATTEMPT
TO SQUEEZE COHEN.
HE IS THE LAWYER.
HE IS THE GUY WHO KNOWS ALL
THE FACTS ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP.
AND TO GET HIM TO TURN
AGAINST HIS CLIENT.
LOOK, THIS IS A VERY
DANGEROUS DAY TODAY FOR
LAWYER-CLIENT RELATIONS.
I DEAL WITH CLIENTS ALL THE
TIME.
I TELL THEM ON MY WORD OF
HONOR THAT WHAT YOU TELL ME
IS SACCO SANK.
NOW
SAW
SACCO -- SACK
SACCO -- SACROSANCT.
THEY CAN BURST INTO THE
OFFICE, GRAB ALL THE
COMPUTERS AND GIVE IT TO
ANOTHER FBI AGENT AND SAY
YOU ARE THE FIRE WALL.
WE WANT YOU NOW TO READ ALL
THESE CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS.
TELL US WHICH ONES WE CAN
GET AND WHICH ONES WE CAN'T
GET.
YOU KNOW, IF THIS WERE THE
SHOE ON THE OTHER FOOT.
IF THIS WERE HILLARY
CLINTON.
BEING INVESTIGATED.
AND THEY WENT INTO HER
LAWYER'S OFFICE, THE ACLU
WOULD BE ON EVERY TELEVISION
STATION IN AMERICA JUMPING
UP AND DOWN.
THE DEAFENING SILENCE OF THE
ACLU AND CIVIL.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT SOURCES
CLOSE TO THE PRESIDENT THIS
IS AGGRESSIVE, THIS IS TO
SQUEEZE THE PRESIDENT, THIS
IS THE END OF ANY
NEGOTIATIONS OR ANY CHANCE
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL
EVER TALK WITH MUELLER AND
HIS TEAM OF INVESTIGATORS?
MORE IMPORTANTLY, LOOK AT
THE TEAM.
HAVE YOU PEOPLE THAT HE
APPOINTED THAT HAVE WITHHELD
AND BE FOUND TO HAVE
WITHHELD EXCULPATORY
EVIDENCE IN MULTIPLE CASES.
>> UM-HUH.
>> Sean: I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THAT TO YOU.
>> ONE THING FIRST.
WHEN LAWYERS THINK ABOUT
CUPITOING WITH THE
PROSECUTORS, THEY HAVE TO
KNOW -- COOPERATING WITH THE
KNOW IN EXCHANGE FOR THE
PROSECUTION THEY WILL BE
TREATED DECENTLY.
HERE HAVE YOU TRUMP'S
LAWYERS COOPERATING
COMPLETELY.
COHEN COOPERATED COMPLETELY.
WHAT DID THEY GET FOR IT A
RAID ON THE OFFICE WITH
EVERYTHING BEING TAKEN.
SO THIS SENDS A POWERFUL
MESSAGE THAT COOPERATION IS
NOT GOING TO BE REWARDED BY
MUELLER.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
REWARDED BY THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT.
I THINK THE RESULT MAY VERY
WELL BE FAR LESS
COOPERATION.
>> Sean: WHAT WOULD YOUR
ADVICE BE IF I WERE TO ASK
YOU IF YOU WERE TALKING TO
THE PRESIDENT TONIGHT, I
WOULD SAY ALL BETS ARE OFF
IT'S CLEAR MUELLER HAS A
I HAVE BEEN ARGUING WITH
DIFFERENT PEOPLE I KNOW.
IF YOU OR ROBERT MUELLER,
AND YOU MADE A COMMENT ON A
RADIO SHOW IN NEW YORK ABOUT
THE WHITEY BULGER.
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN BOSTON.
>> WE REMEMBER THAT VERY
WELL.
OH, SURE.
>> Sean: FOUR MEN WENT TO
JAIL.
MUELLER WAS INVOLVED IN THE
CASE.
TWO OF THEM DIED IN JAIL.
THEY WERE ALL LATER
EXONERATED.
OVER 100-MILLION-DOLLAR
JUDGMENT WAS PAID.
AND ISSUES INVOLVING
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE WAS
THERE.
ALSO HIS PIT BULL ANDREW
WEISSMANN.
10S OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS
LOST BECAUSE OF HIS TACTICS
AT ANDERSON ACCOUNTING.
-0 DECISION AGAINST HIM IN
THE SUPREME COURT.
FOUR MERRILL EXECUTIVES IN
JAIL.
THAT WAS OVERTURNED BY THE
FIFTH CIRCUIT.
AND TWO EXAMPLES OF HIM
WITHHOLDING EXCULL THAT PORE
EVIDENCE.
HE DIDN'T APPOINT WISEMAN TO
BE A POTTED PLANT.
HE KNEW HIS BACKGROUND.
WHAT DOES IT SAY ABOUT
MUELLER AND HIS TEAM?
>> WELL, THEY ARE ZEALOUS.
MANY PEOPLE THINK THEY ARE
ZOFER ZEALOUS.
I DON'T THINK THEY ARE
PARTISANS.
HERE YOU AND I MIGHT
DISAGREE.
I DON'T THINK THEY CARE
WHETHER THEY HURT THE
DEMOCRATS OR THE
REPUBLICANS.
SOME ON THE TEAM MAY.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S
MUELLER'S APPROACH.
IS HE JUST DETERMINED TO GET
HIS TARGET.
AND, WHEN YOU APPOINT
SOMEBODY TO BE A SPECIAL
COUNSEL, THERE IS A TARGET
ON THE BACK OF THE
PRESIDENT.
THE TARGET ON THE BACK OF
PEOPLE CLOSE TO THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: HAS HE LOST
PERSPECTIVE?
>> I THINK HE HAS LOST
PERSPECTIVE.
I THINK THAT HAPPENS WHEN
OVER ZEALOUS PROSECUTORS ARE
GIVEN A TARGET.
AND THE CONCERN NOW IS THAT
THERE WON'T BE COOPERATION.
I THINK WE WILL NOW SEE A
SCORCHED EARTH POLICY ON
BOTH SIDES.
LOOK, I DON'T GIVE ADVICE TO
THE PRESIDENT EXCEPT ON
TELEVISION IF HE WANTS TO
LISTEN, HE CAN LISTEN.
IF I WERE THE PRESIDENT, I
WOULD AT LEAST SERIOUSLY
CONSIDER GOING TO COURT
TOMORROW, SEEKING TO HAVE A
JUDGE GET AHOLD OF ALL THE
LAWYER CLIENT MATERIAL, TAKE
IT AWAY FROM THE PROSECUTOR,
TAKE IT AWAY FROM THE FBI.
DON'T LET AN FBI AGENT LOOK
AT ANY OF THEM.
>> Sean: THEY HAVE ALREADY
LOOKED AT.
>> HAVE THE JUDGE GO THROUGH
IT AND HAVE THE JUDGE MAKE A
DETERMINATION AS TO WHETHER
THERE IS ANYTHING IN THERE
THAT IS LAWYER CLIENT
PRIVILEGE.
>> Sean: AT THIS POINT
THOUGH, I DON'T SEE HOW THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS TEAM COULD
COOPERATE.
>> IT'S HARD.
IT'S HARD.
THINK ARE NOT GETTING
ANYTHING IN RETURN.
COOPERATION HAS TO BE A
TWO-WAY STREET.
NOW, THE PROBLEM, OF COURSE,
FOR THE PRESIDENT, IS THAT
MUELLER ULTIMATELY HOLDS THE
CARD IN WHICH HE CAN
SUBPOENA THE PRESIDENT, CALL
HIM IN FRONT OF A GRAND JURY
WITHOUT HIS LAWYER, WITHOUT
RESTRICTIONS.
IT MAY BE LESS WORSE FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO MAKE A DEAL AND
SIT DOWN AND HAVE A FOUR
HOUR CONFERENCE.
>> Sean: PRESIDENT NOT
ANSWER AT THAT POINT.
>> HE COULD NOT ANSWER
CERTAIN QUESTIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE, IF HE IS ASKED
WHY DID YOU FIRE COMEY, HIS
ANSWER.
>> Sean: ROD ROSENSTEIN TOLD
ME.
>> THAT'S ONE ANSWER.
SOMEHOW ROD ROSENSTEIN STILL
ON THE CASE.
THE OTHER ANSWER YOU CAN'T
QUESTION THE PRESIDENT'S
ARTICLE 2 DECISION-MAKING
AUTHORITY.
JUST LIKE THE CONSTITUTION
SAYS YOU CAN'T QUESTION
SENATORS.
THE SUPREME COURT HAS SAID
YOU CAN'T QUESTION JUDGES
ABOUT THEIR DECISIONS.
YOU CAN'T QUESTION A
PRESIDENT ABOUT DECISIONS HE
MADE THAT HE WAS AUTHORIZED
TO MAKE UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION.
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION.
DOLLS THIS NOW GO ON
POTENTIALLY FOR YEARS, WELL
PAST THE MID TERMS?
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION.
>> Sean: IS THERE GOING TO
BE A FIGHT.
>> I CAN'T IMAGINE HOW THIS
ENDS BEFORE THE MID TERMS.
IF IT ENDS JUST BEFORE THE
MID TERMS, WITH A REPORT
THAT'S CONDEMN TORE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION, IMAGINE THE
OUTRAGE THAT WILL OCCUR IF,
AGAIN WE SEE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT POTENTIALLY
IMPACTING AN ELECTION.
>> Sean: MUELLER WANTED
THIS.
HE SAT OUT TO DO THIS.
WHEN HE GAVE THIS TO THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW
YORK TODAY.
THAT'S WHAT HIS PLAN WAS.
>> I THINK HIS PLAN WAS TO
SQUEEZE.
TO TRY TO MAKE SURE HE STAYS
WITHIN HIS MANDATE, BUT THEN
TO USE THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT
TO SQUEEZE COHEN.
IF THEY CAN GET COHEN TO
BECOME A COOPERATING